okay for george what's your favorite
piece of writing that you've ever
produced even hearkening back
to your youth
yeah i don't know that one is like
asking a parent well which is your
favorite child
yeah mind you they all have favorite
children they just won't admit it
so what's yours you know i i
some of the my favorite children who
live in my head i haven't actually
looked
at a reread for for decades and probably
would be wise to keep it that way
uh obviously a game of thrones the song
of ice and fire is going to be
what i'm remembered for if i'm
remembered for anything it's my magnum
opus but it's not finished yet
and therefore i i'm still nervous about
you know
will i stick to landing here uh will i
will i bring it in as powerfully as i
hope to bring it in
and make it a complete work of art with
a beginning middle and end
that's my goal i have done other things
that i have finished i mean i started
out writing short stories and i
a lot of my short stories yeah i
produced some stinkers and uh some that
were kind of mediocre but i also
produced some that were very i'm very
proud of a song for leia my first hugo
winner um
sand kings which oddly enough i didn't
think much of when i wrote it but i
went on to become my until game of
thrones my most
popular work and the one everybody knew
me for sand kings
um a few of the more obscure stories
like
this tower of ashes or the stone city i
was really
that was i think my science fiction as
the best the
best it got um some of my earlier
standalone novels
fever dream will always have a very
special
place in my heart and uh the armageddon
rag
uh you know i i kind of have a love-hate
relationship with that novel because i
was very proud of it i still am proud of
it
i think it's an important novel i'm glad
i wrote it it almost destroyed my career
no one bought it and i couldn't sell any
novel after it so uh
it changed the course of my life in some
huge and
fundamental ways but uh nonetheless
i still have a affection for that it's
interesting that
you know tv having been historically
regarded as kind of
the lower form than film is actually
more
useful for exploring a world in great
detail so it's kind of reminding me of
the way
science fiction and fantasy's fortunes
have changed it seems like
tv is now being seen as something that
you know you can have
really wonderful art and you know carry
something out for a longer period of
time
well it's true that historically uh you
know
future films were the the highest level
in hollywood and television was seen as
a at the lower level so
the snob factor that we talked about in
the literary canon also exists there
but that's completely changed now i mean
feature films have come
to be the place to go for spectacle but
if you want serious drama and character
development all that then it's
television we are living
i mean forget the early 50s that was a
great age this is the golden age
television there have been never been
so many great television shows on and
the the quality of a of a television
show of today's television shows like
game of thrones
uh holds up to any feature film i mean
we've
we've showed uh game of thrones episodes
on imac screens
you know blown up to to the size of a
football stadium and then it still looks
great which you can say for
you know i mean don't put any star trek
episodes even the next generation
certainly not the original series on an
imac screen
it's not going to work that way the
cardboard the special effects of
cinematography
all of the production values of the best
television shows are right up there with
any feature film
and uh more and more directors and
writers
and actors who previously only did
features
are now moving into television so it's
exciting it's a great new world for
people who like television and
they're really more good shows than i
could even keep up with
let's see what we have here uh when
writing about a given character
you attempt to quote inhabit them
psychologically physiologically
etc if so how do you get in the frame of
mind
uh yes i do inhabit them odd as it may
seem
i i am you know some of my time i am a
dwarf and uh some of the time i'm an
incredibly hot chick riding a dragon
[Laughter]
[Applause]
some of the time i'm a psychopathic 10
year old girl
killing people and slitting their
throats so
i guess my mood varies but uh
changing between them is very difficult
i mean i do not write the chapters in
the order in which you read them i
you know i'm if i'm in a tyrion groove i
will write
you know three or four tyrion chapters
and uh
then say well i'm almost to the end of
the tyrion stuff for this book i better
stop and
write about somebody else but that
transition where i stop writing about
tyrion for a while and then i go write
three or four
jon snow chapters that's a tough
transition because they are very
different
and they have different voices they know
different people i have to
re-read a bunch of the old chapters to
remember where they were and what they
sounded like and
i usually have a couple false starts
when when changing but
yeah i live inside my characters the
viewpoint characters anyway